hey everyone welcome to pax prime I'm
Peter Brown I'm here join them by my
friend and my boss Randolph Ramsey let's
let's let's not get too formal with each
other ok how are you I'm great man and I
know that you got a chance to go see a
game called a city sleep that's right
it's the new one from harmonix and it's
kind of a I guess a a weird direction
they sort of like popped up with this
game at the starter packs and it's
something that you normally wouldn't
expect for them so it's a shmup yeah
which as people will know it shoot him
up a bit of a bullet hell shooter I
think we're seeing some footage of it
now and you know a couple of the guys
that work on chroma yeah which was that
shooter that you know the harmonic stars
were developing and talked about the
start of this year was going to be like
a rhythm based first person shooter so
you know while they're working on their
then trying to retool and trying to find
out what they want to do with that game
yeah you know they had a few folks you
know do a side project and you know
taking a lot of the stuff that they
learnt from you know trying to do a
shooter with in something like chroma
into a bullet hell shooter like this and
you know like the two lead guys and this
I apparently are sort of massive fans of
the genre and as you can see right now
it's a lot of bullets so screen yeah I
mean we talked about harmonics and you
brought it up at croma but I need to
know what's going on here because
they're known for their games that
incorporate music and rhythm now is that
a part of the gameplay itself or his
music just sort of emphasize so music is
heavily emphasized because you're right
it is harmonics harmonics title so you
know they're always going to be about
the music it's not similar to anything
else I've done in that you're not
actually beat matching so you're not you
know you're not shooting to create a
beer or anything like that so there is
like you know a strong sort of like
hip-hop ish soundtrack that goes through
at it the the level itself is sort of
map to you know matching like the beats
and rhythm of the music itself but you
know it's not actually like
like a specific sort of like note
matching thing like you would have had
in a rock band or you know any other
thing that they've done in a recent past
the shoot-'em-up genre has a really
strong following in Japan it's not as
big in North America no it's not we had
a game come out about two years ago
called sin amaura that was made by a
Hungarian studio with grasshopper
manufacture from Japan yeah that was a
really nice mix on the sort of shmoop
you know genre but in one thing I'm
wondering is does this game have
hardcore appeal because harmonics
doesn't typically make games for people
better fans of shmups it's interesting
you say that actually because you know
like the to lead us for this apparently
are sort of huge shmup chance oh no they
did not want to actually dumb it down
for more Western audience so you know
they are you know trying to make sure
that this has the same type of Appeal as
you know as like as a really hardcore
japanese Schmo so what we're seeing on
the screen here i believe is actually
just on easy difficulty okay so you know
it will be you know but you can get a
lot more challenging so you know in
higher difficulties you know like the
boss the bullet patterns will be
different and that's typical for some up
you see that little the blue dot in the
middle of your character po yeah that's
actually your hitbox okay so you know
you just have to be really accurate you
know with how you actually maneuver and
and the thing that's a glowing green
right now there's I think you know two
of the I guess that you need more unique
things that you know how monitors trying
to to put into this game so PO she's a
dream Exorcist and your main character
in the game of course has access to
these three so like ghost powers just
you can deploy at any time so you know
one will give a health so it's
disappeared right now but does screen
before like that green thing that was
that was sort of like pulsing would give
our pulses of like green that you can
catch to them to boost your health and
another one is like for attack and
another one is like boost your defense
so you can switch that out on the fly
and you can see the sort of the menu
just popping up around you can like
choose which ones that you can actually
do I like to deploy so we're seeing a
boss battle now and I gotta say Peter
you know i'm not a huge shmup guy so you
know i mean you're much more familiar
with the genre like from what you're
seeing here like you know that does it
is it really evocative of you know i'm
not to japanese titles at least in terms
of the the don maku like you know the
the curtain of bullets as a sort of
referred to like yeah you definitely had
those elements in for an easy mode it's
pretty interesting i'm curious to see
how the hitbox is going to change yeah
i'm assuming if the game is on a higher
difficulty sitting that hitbox is going
to be a little bit larger yeah but as it
is yeah i mean it does seem to have you
know the elements that you'd look for it
it is a little bit unusual in that you
can move anywhere on the screen and fire
in any direction but but that's sort of
interesting element it's curious to see
what harmonics can do with this because
they're fans of the genre but it's their
first time doing it but I think they
might bring something really interesting
and what's really interesting too is you
know the development of this has been
quite unique I guess for the studio so
you know they're trying to do a little
bit of a double Flying type thing in
which they've all broken up into smaller
teams trying to iterate really quickly
trying to come up with game concepts and
just seeing what actually sort of flies
and sticks and what skull appeal and
this is the first one really that you
know so utilizing the new model okay and
it's coming out to pc and mac via steam
dates and mines yeah i think they've got
a date for october i don't have the
exact date but we can sort of update
that layer all right well that city
sleeps by Harmonix coming to PC Mac
pretty soon see two new gamespot com we
have a whole lot more packs coverage on
the way
you